theory with the black
pieces and um first we're just gonna
hear from magnus what he said after
winning game three
at least no one can claim that you're
not creating entertainment in your game
same on this no this is um this was good
i think he made a pretty serious
misjudgment at some point when he
uh decided to give up the second bishop
um i feel like as long as there is
nothing concrete for him
in terms of attack i'm just better
positionally
and
maybe there was something but he
couldn't couldn't quite find it and then
you know it fell apart surprisingly
quickly and is this also a result of you
having such a wide array of opening
repertoires no sure i mean
but he was also he was also out for for
a fight when i decided to play something
um
something uh fighting he um
he tried to play for a win as well so
that was that was fair enough um but i
think yeah as i said position was pretty
pretty normal i think
quite fine for me but then he just
misjudged the position draw with a white
would secure the match does that mean
that we're gonna see something a little
more sane in this last fourth game i
will see
good luck thank you
yeah android is enough for magnus in
this game are we seeing something sane
something insane but not drawish
magnus definitely keeping the game alive
all the pieces still on the board
it's really nice to see a lot of the top
players when they just need a draw with
white they're quite cynical um i've been
the same myself in the past just if you
need a draw just
drop uh swap of all the pieces
get all the risk out of the position but
magnus okay first trade of the of the
position he's just playing chess and
you've got um you've got a lot of pieces
on the board so i think anisha's picked
a line where she must have played here
uh yeah so it's it's interesting and uh
the reason i like this type of hippo
setup
it's just so flexible the position if it
opens up will favor the black bishops
and any attempt to open up one side of
the board is just met by a block for
example if white pushes here now it will
just be blocked up and okay instead
magnus decides to just push his queen
forward
i'm guessing black is going to do the
same
and black will move his queen to this
square and you're right simon it's just
a guessing game um here we go black is
just wallowing in his first couple of
ranks right just sitting waiting and is
white going to be brave enough to castle
this side is that going to be brave
enough to castle this side
yeah plans are so complex
it's a bit of a guessing game yeah
definitely
i mean it's so tense i mean i use this
word a lot but we've seen so many games
that have been
very very just
intense is the right word nervy and uh
here
i mean white has a lot of space actually
black on the other hand is quite cramped
i had a similar thing and against evan
chuck and a
like online tournament and he did he did
he just castled kingside in the end so
but uh um you don't want to play that
more foolish than brave probably yeah
and you called it simon um it's the
dutch player in you you just want to
push your f1 love pushing the f pawn on
freddy at the board and i also like the
idea of pushing the e pawn you know at
some point i want to just kill black
basically blow it open uh yeah because
you know the black king's in the middle
i know my king's in the middle but my
piece is a better place because of this
lovely positioning of the night that
you've mentioned yeah this looks very
scary at some point if
if you can achieve it i'm not really
sure what anish's plan is with this
queen move i guess his whole idea is to
capture this pawn without running into a
knight
night jump but wow magnus i mean the
safer option would probably be castling
this flank castling this side of the
board but he chooses to castle the other
way and uh
i mean he's not scared the white king
black needs 10 moves to attack it
well it's getting dramatic for anish
geary must win situation here in game
four and actually
what a start to the ftx crypto cup
because all the matches that are now
playing game fours there's must-win
situations for frugia and for liam lea
to take it to thai breaks anish yuri
fighting for his life in this first
round against magnus carlsen and a bunch
of moves
watch your moves yeah i was going to say
he has to use his magic wand here and
maybe he has with that move pushing on
the queen side trying to break open that
area of the board yep
take this pawn uh magnus hasn't taken
that one but uh here for example you
could just give a check the black king
moves and you're right you could at the
very least just park your king on the
square put a knight on this square
you'll never get checkmated yeah but uh
magnus he wants to checkmate instead he
wants to finish it off he wants to see
us do that dance
i think he will just go e5 and checkmate
i mean like look at the black king
white's pieces are now ready i mean i'm
not even calculating that move i'm just
like you know it's just such a natural
move to play
check with the bishop clear the lines
open and kill
um it's
probably that you know as simple as that
but you're right this check is the
killer one um you give up a pawn but
like you said magnus won't even
calculate this one he'll just see that
okay he's given up a born he'll check
the black king there we go he plays it
instantly and wherever the black king
goes it's going to be stuck in the
center forever and with all the heavy
pieces on the board with all the
ammunition the rooks the queens
eventually this king will
yeah it's just not going to survive
movie music so i would have some hand
zimmer some time you know yeah
big ones yeah yeah
exactly build them up yeah and then they
suddenly come to this big crescendo and
yeah yeah
just yeah you feel like you're doing
something special though i like it yeah
that's cool black is trying his best to
break through towards the white king but
if you look at attacking pieces black
has no attackers around the white king
and okay magnus doesn't even capture a
pawn back
um i was going to say as well before
this game one thing i would love to see
in the tour is a beauty prize like the
most brilliant game prize for each event
and magnus is trying to achieve that now
um okay a pawn was captured the white
queen swings across and look at the
white knights look at the black king
the white bishop's beautiful the white
pawn on the e6 square i can't really see
a move for black that's the other
problem i mean black can't okay if you
have to make a move like this you're
he's setting the pieces up ready for the
next game yeah let's just push it back
on its starting square and you still got
to finish this position off but
even if he might do it i don't know even
if he breaks all the ruse rules swaps
off the queens
i mean you're attacking has done that
he's done it
the curse of the commentator comes just
don't swallow it and he's done it
but yeah
that was just unfortunate
it's a killer yeah the problem is black
has two pieces under attack if you save
the rook and continue uh defending your
bishop i mean white can win in a few
ways here i think you could win with
giving a check but for example even if
you trade off here and then just plant
your knight into its dream square you're
just going to push this pawn forward and
it will become a queen
again black is completely stuck black
just cannot move
and there we go magnus plays the simple
approach he trades off and this pawn is
going to win the game uh we'll see a
result any moment this pawn will step
forward
you're actually threatening for example
if black moves a pawn you're threatening
to give a check with your rook
and uh here admit
sorry i'm just being lovely flashy here
fork and the king moves you make a new
queen and you checkmate shortly we'll
see anishkari resign right now um it's
just complete domination magnus
he's up to his level the last two games
yeah beautiful game
yeah just masterclass this last one in
the opening this is why we learn
openings just to get a position you
understand well put your pieces on good
squares
middle games we come up with plans here
magnus came up with this attacking plan
and then uh yeah just a bit of
calculation and that will finish it off
anisha's not even looking at his screen
right now he's ready to resign
he knows this last game has been
a bit brutal yeah
gonna be interesting too here from
magnus carlsen so in the first major the
oslo esports cup magnus was struggling a
lot with being sick he was a sick guy
the first five days or something of that
tournament
and he didn't win it he was struggling
with his form we know he is out to win
this tournament and what a start to the
day it's over winning also game four
magnus carlsen